This episode is brought to you by grounds news.
Ground news is an app that is dedicated to fighting misinformation and bias
news, which I think we all know is a bit of a problem in today's media.
It's really harder than ever out there to work out.
What is really happening in the news.
Ground news allows you to filter the news by political bias.
So you can jump into the app and you can see the same story being brought to you
by left-wing center. And right-wing sources.
This allows you to understand the different perspectives and form your own
opinion about what's going on in the world.
They've gotten used from over 40,000 news outlets from around the world.
So you can not only see the political bias of a piece of reporting,
but also how it might be reported differently in a different country.
Ground news is a free app available from both the Apple app store and the Google
play store. Just click the link in the description below,
and let's get into the video.
It's the biggest scandal in us history on August the eighth, 1974,
Richard Milhous Nixon became the first ever president to resign mere days before
Congress could impeach him.
The cause of this epoch shaping events was the Watergate scandal and attempted
wiretapping of the democratic national election headquarters and its subsequent
coverup. Even now after four decades of scandals, as varied as Iran,
Contra Monica Lewinsky, and one of the hell was happening in 2016,
Watergate remains the gold standard of high crimes and misdemeanors Gators even
entered the lexicon as a suffix denoting scandal.
But while most of us are aware of Watergate,
how much do we really know about the man behind the door?
Born into a blue collar family in 1913,
Richard Nixon was a natural political animal throughout his house and Senate
careers.
He under reputation as a formidable opponent first designs and how his VP Denis
presidents in his own, right?
He oversaw initiatives that transformed America yet the 37th president would
wind up dynamiting his own legacy in the most dramatic way possible flawed
paranoid brilliance. This is the tale of Richard Nixon. The most controversial.
Precedence.
Tire of saying the 37th president came from a hard background born on January
the ninth, 1913 in Yorba Linda, California, Richard Milhous,
Nixon grew up not in a fancy mansion,
but rather in a modest home that he shared with four siblings is perpetually
angry.
Father Frank owned a service station and a small feeling citrus farm that never
brought in much more than a handful of pennies as Nixon would later reminisce,
we were poor, but the glory of it was that we didn't know it.
However you could argue this statement was not entirely accurate for his entire
adult life.
Nixon would privately rail against those born with a silver spoon in their mouth
as the Kennedys or the wealthy New York Jews that he perceived as enemies.
Young Nixon may well have been poor,
but he very much seemed to know it still,
this wasn't the source of grinding soul sapping poverty that hollows you out.
Growing up Nixon found time to read stacks of books,
run for class president and engage as quake a mother in energetic debates.
It was in these good-natured arguments that he got his first taste of politics.
The dawning of the 1920s brought a string of bad news for the Nixon family.
First,
the family citrus farm went under forcing them to leave their home and move to
nearby Whittier.
Then Nixon's youngest brother Arthur died in 1925 aged only seven a few years
later, his oldest brother,
Harold also passed away suffering a long and lingering death from tuberculosis.
It was a traumatic time for the family,
but you wouldn't know it from looking at Nixon Whittier high school.
The boy was excelling eventually graduating second in his class,
he was offered a scholarship to Harvard, but alas,
the family was too poor to send them away.
Instead Nixon had to make do with a local Quaker college.
Still the boy applied himself, earning a reputation as a debate champion,
a great football player and a charismatic character in the school's drama
productions. When he graduated in 1934,
Nixon was so red hot that Duke university's law school practically threw a
scholarship at him by 1937,
Nixon was a 24 year old qualified lawyer with some of the best grades in the
whole state. He should have been set for life after that,
but things weren't so easy for a boy from a hardscrabble background,
every prestigious law firm next and applied to turn him down,
stung Nixon slunk back to Whittier.
He moved in above his parents' garage and got a dead end job at a small law firm
and just contemplated how unfair life was here.
He was a gifted boy with the grades to match to summit because why?
Because his parents didn't have any money.
But while returning to Whittier would leave a bitter taste that Nixon would
never shake. It did at least have one positive outcome. In 1938,
Nixon joined a local community theater there as a rehearsal on January the 18th,
he met Thelma. Katherine Ryan known to our friends is Pat.
She was glamorous beguiling after driving our home that evening,
the young lawyer declared I'd like to have a date with you to which she replied.
I'm busy, not exactly a fairytale romance starting right there,
but Nixon persevered when he heard pats enjoyed ice skating sport had never
tried. He spent weeks forcing himself to learn how to skate just so he could
accidentally meet her at the rink. Finally, after a year as just friends,
Pat caved. And she agreed to that date on the 21st of June, 1940 next and,
and Pat were married together.
They agreed to keep chasing their dreams to keep being ambitious.
Two years later, they moved from California to Washington DC,
where Nixon got a job in the office of price administration.
It was the 29 year old's first foray into the world of politics.
And it certainly was not going to be as lost
Nixon lasted less than a year in the office of price administration and FDR new
deal program. It was the embodiment of big government,
something that chilled Nixon to his soul and he quit and discussed rather than
return to practicing law. He joined the Navy.
This was a pretty impressive thing to do as a Quaker.
Nixon was exempt from serving of a get out of jail free card,
considering the massive bloody war going on,
but Nixon enlisted regardless serving in the Pacific.
Although he never saw combat,
he still managed to pick up two service dogs before resigning his commission in
January, 1946,
barely had Nixon swapped his starched white uniform for a dull gray suits.
Then a group of Republicans from his hometown approached him with an interesting
proposition. Five term Democrats.
Jerry voyeurs was up for reelection in California's 12th district,
despite being soft on communism,
no Republican had ever been able to unseat him butts with a war hero as their
candidate. Then maybe just maybe it was possible throughout 1946,
Nixon went for the election with the same bloody mindedness.
It shown pursuing Pat despite his reputation, voices,
actual connections to communism non-existence so Nixon,
why don't he just made them up at a town hall debate and Nixon flourished a
scrap of paper, supposedly linking voyeurs to a communist blinked pack.
Nevermind that Nixon was actually talking about a completely different pack and
never mind that voice was against communism in voters' minds.
The Democrats was now a read come November. They voted for Nixon in droves.
It was Nixon's first experience with negative campaigning.
The art of not making yourself look good,
but rather making your opponent look worse. And well,
Nixon was a bit of a genius at it. After a short stint in the house,
which included the successful prosecution of alga,
his state department deployed on Soviet stooge. Nixon ran for the Senate.
This time has campaigning was so negative.
It's approached absolute zero Nixon slandered.
His opponent does pink right down to our underwear.
His staff handing out pink sheets, falsely comparing her voting records.
A lot of communists as it did in 1946.
It works and Nixon became Senator. However,
he also picked up something else alongside his Senate seat, a ghosted,
the negative campaign, the California press branded Nixon, tricky Dick.
It was a nickname that would stick with him for life.
But what did Dick mix and cab from a Bryant blue collar kid spurned by elite
C had gone on to become a Washington insider and his meteoric rise was not
going to stop that in 1952, Republican nominee,
Dwight D Eisenhower picked tricky Dick to be his running mate,
hoping that Nixon's California roots would win him the West.
It was Nixon's ticket to the big leagues,
but it was also nearly his undoing that sometime though the New York post
splashed,
a story of a secret Nixon slush fund using campaign donations to support his
lifestyle,
although untrue it nearly torpedoed Nixon's trances Eisenhower called in and
basically said, looked it sought out there's massive balls up,
or I'm going to find a new VP. Got it. And Nixon. Well,
he got it on September the 23rd, 1952,
Richard Nixon went on TV to explain himself.
It was the first ever political speech televised live drawing a staggering 60
million viewers before the old Nixon laid bare his finances in painful pitiful
detail, painting a picture of a struggling relatable man.
This beach was full of pathetic human touches, such as when Nixon confessed.
Pat doesn't have a mink coat,
but she does have a respectable Republican cloth coat.
And I always tell her that she'd looked good in anything.
But what made the speech famous was when Nixon announced he had been given one
political gift, a Cocker spaniel named checkers that his children loved and.
They were going to keep that dog known as the check his speech today,
the live broadcast saved Nixon's career Eisenhower calls him up and declared
yo, my boy, then November the fourth,
the Eisenhower Nixon ticket won in a landslide.
It now seems that Dick Nixon's rise was unstoppable.
There's noise in our quote, that brilliantly sums up Nixon's time.
As VP asked by a reporter, what policies his Veep had contributed Eisenhower.
Riley replied. If you gave me a week, I might think of one,
but while Nixon wasn't transforming the nation as VP,
he was still working hard on his main project to make Richard Nixon look as much
like a future president as possible.
There's been doing stuff like going on a tour of Venezuela,
where he won praise for Cooley dealing with an anti-American mob and then stuff
like traveling to the USSR where he engaged premier Nikita Khrushchev in a
spirited debate inside a model American kitchen in this quest Nixon was helped
by Eisenhower's failing health starting in 1955,
Eisenhower suffered a series of heart attacks that often left Nixon as defacto
president. Despite worries, that had used as temporary role as a bully pulpit,
Nixon won plaudits as a sober and sensible leader.
So when Eisenhower's second term expired and it became time to pick the next
Republican nominee, everyone was squarely behind Nixon. With his experience.
Nixon hopes,
the 1960 election would be a cakewalk continuing his unstoppable rise.
Unfortunately,
the blue collar boy was about to go slamming into the glass ceiling.
You will know the tale of the 1960 election and how fresh faced vibrant.
John Kennedy completely blew stuffy old Nixon out of the water,
but while most people credit JFK's media analysis wise pick of Lyndon Johnson as
his running mate for his victory, Nixon sores.
Another way as the presidency slipped from his grasp.
But Nixon became convinced that the true culprit wasn't Kennedy's charisma or
even the recent recession, it was Kennedy's money.
As far as Nixon was concerned,
this was just another case of the elites screwing over the working class.
By that November,
he felt he didn't lose the presidency so much as have it stolen from him.
It was the end of Nixon's rise and the start of his long fall,
his career in tatters, Nixon returned to California.
Their local Republicans convinced him to run for governor just two years after
failing to become president Nixon lost California's gubernatorial race by a
depressing margin in the wake of the defeat,
Nixon called a press conference where he bitterly declared you won't have Nixon
to kick around anymore because gentlemen, this is my last press conference.
What followed was a period in the political wilderness and being the political
wilderness.
It was way more comfortable than the actual wilderness and saw Nixon rich for
the first time from his law practice.
It also saw the former political Streetfighter refashion himself as an elder
statesman making measured observations on the Vietnam war. However,
Nixon was still politically minded enough to campaign for Barry Goldwater at the
1964 election.
Although Goldwater lost Nixon support made him a darling of the Republican,
right? It was almost like Nixon was courting conservatives, building himself,
a power base in Casey ever decided to run for president. Again,
it was a shrewd move as 1968 approach the Republican party began searching for
its next standard. Bear up.
The obvious choice was an electrifying rising staff in California,
a former actor, Chris,
and the future of the party that actor's name was Ronald Reagan.
And he'd go on to transform the GOPs fortunes,
but not in 1968 as Reagan's popularity grew and Nixon craps back out of
the shadows.
He began approaching prominent conservatives ensuring they lined up behind him.
By the time Reagan's campaign really got underway,
the nomination had already been sewn up that August, 1968,
Nixon was unanimously declared Republican nominee by now,
Democrats were in chaos. Lyndon B Johnson had refused run.
The convention had seen riots in front runner.
Bobby Kennedy had been assassinated against that kind of backdrop.
What else could possibly happen on November the fifth, 1968,
Richard Nixon swept to the electoral college to win.
The presidency has popular vote share. 43% was one of the lowest in history.
These in a way by third-party candidate, George Wallace,
but when we're still a win against all odds,
he had shown them had shown up those stuck elites, those Kennedys,
those New York liberals and the next scenario had now begun and tricky.
Dick was set and it would go down in history.
Normally.
Presidential biographics. This would be the point to talk you through that.
I'm in office, hopefully with some jokes thrown in as well.
But since this video is only about 26 minutes long,
and we've still got a massive thing called Watergate to discuss,
we're going to have to just give you the barest overview of the Nixon
presidency. And that's a shame because there's so much to talk about.
Take school busing. Although education had been desegregated under Eisenhower,
geographic separation, most schools were still mano colored.
One solution was school busing,
which involved busing black children into white schools.
Although Nixon was against the practice.
The Supreme court ruling forced him to enforce it Dick's solution.
Well that was new federalism at its heart.
New federalism was desegregation but done by local communities rather than the
government by racial communities were established across the South.
Each charged with implementing desegregation rather than simply passing the
buck. It's actually worked between Nixon's election in 1970,
the number of black kids in racially segregated schools dropped from 70% to only
18%. Then there's the environment. If you're below a certain age,
the words Republican presidents plus environments probably come to images of
guys in expensive suits, pouring gallons of oil on to baby seals,
but not Nixon tricky.
Dick was well aware that green issues were a vote winner among moderate
Democrats. So he leaned into them.
It was on Nixon's watch that the environmental protection agency was created and
the clean air act passed. And other thing,
Dick Nixon supported or women's rights.
Well Nixon's environmentalism came mostly from cynical vote.
Grabbing his desire for gender equality was mostly sincere.
Nixon directed the federal government launched affirmative action on women's
rights and pass legislation like title nine for bidding sex discrimination in
education. Then there was war.
It was Nixon who started both the war on cancer, the war on drugs,
plus the actual war in Cambodia after he authorized us incursions.
That last one, by the way,
led to one of the most infamous non Watergate moments of his presidency.
On may the fourth,
1970 peaceful demonstrators gathered a Kent state there before hundreds of
witnesses,
the Ohio national guard shot down for unarmed people and injured another nine,
despite massive public outcry,
the Nixon white house didn't prosecute any guardsmen.
The last major Nixon initiative we should talk about is China in February, 1972,
Nixon surprised the world by going to visit the middle kingdom surprised because
until that point, China had been America's bogeyman number two,
all right behind the USSR.
But Nixon realized he could keep the USSR in check by cozying up to Beijing.
Although the move was cynical,
it's now seen as the moment communist China started opening up to the world.
So they have it four years of Nixon,
four of the most dramatic years in modern us history condensed in to about 400
words.
We still had to leave so much out from the oil crisis to ending the draft to the
Nixon shock that ended Bretton woods and set the stage for a decade of
stagflation. Still,
at least you're now aware that there was more to the Nixon presidency than
merely scandal, especially as we move towards the biggest scandal of all,
because it's finally time to talk about Watergate.
[Inaudible].
There's one saying I'm a set it straight, this Watergate,
and that's exactly what I'm going to do for you right now.
And wish me luck because it's super complicated.
Although Nixon's first time was outwardly successful behind the scenes.
Tricky Dick's paranoia was increasing in February of 1971,
the 37th president installed a secret taping system in the white house.
One activated the moment anyone entered the room,
but the real crazy started on June the 13th, 1971. That was the day.
The New York times published the Pentagon papers.
Top-secret documents laying bare American atrocities.
And in competence in Vietnam,
while the papers stopped with Lyndon Johnson's white house,
Nixon was still outraged to the league.
It was from this outrage that the white house plumbers were formed.
A top secret team.
The plumbers were there to stop leaks through the use of spying sabotage and
breaking.
The first step was to break into the office of the shrink who treated the
Pentagon papers leak up.
It wouldn't be the last time the plumbers got involved in something shady.
So let's fast now to 1972,
Nixon is up for reelection and his most likely opponents is the formidable
democratic Senator Edmund Muskie that spring a Basilica set of problems set
musky white voters in early States were harassed by late night phone calls from
rude people who claimed they were black supporters of Muskie.
Others received letters on Muskie stationary that spewed absurd conspiracy
theories about his primary opponents.
And of course it was Nixon back to his old negative campaigning.
Now he had to help from both the plumbers and to the campaign to reelect the
president pleasingly abbreviated to creep and creep would stop at
nothing to fulfill that mission by April,
the precious that torpedoed muskies run,
but the plumbers were still at it at 2:00 AM. On the 17th of June, 1972,
they broke into the Democrat party headquarters in the Watergate office building
intending to bug the place. Instead, they got caught by a security guard.
Within two days,
the Washington post was reporting that one of the burglars was a salaried member
of creep, but Nixon assumed it would just blow over.
He's actually on tape declaring the story will die and saying who the hell is
going to keep it alive.
The two name answer Bob Woodward and Carl Bernstein all through that hot summer.
The post reporters published articles covering creeps,
dirty tricks and linking a Nixon check for $28,000 to one of the Watergate
burglars. But no one was paying any attention behind the scenes.
Nixon was ordering the CIA to interfere with the FBI's Watergate investigation
out in the open,
the Democrats had nominated left-wing populous George McGovern as their
candidate and Nixon was making mincemeat out of him.
Despite the steady trickle of Watergate stories. Nixon crushed McGovern in 1972,
winning one of the biggest landslides in us history. Seriously,
the only comparable victories FDR in 36 and Reagan in 84.
But while the voters had agreed to reinstate Dick into the white house for a
second term,
the wheels were already coming off the presidency just days before Nixon's
inauguration. The seven men involved in Watergate break-in went on trial.
Perhaps Nixon expected them to stay loyal to him. If so,
his trust was misplaced over the next few months,
these seven men would nearly all choose saving their own skins over saving
Nixon. Tricky. Dick couldn't see it yet, but his presidency was already doomed.
Richard Nixon.
Second time is a little like reading Shakespearian tragedy re-imagined as
depressing FOS, barely was Nixon back in the oval office.
Then the walls started closing in on February the seventh,
the Democrat controlled Senate passed resolution 60 establishing the Watergate
hearings. Initially this didn't bother Nixon much.
He went on TV to assure viewers that he was blameless,
but the fullest lay with some rogue AIDS. Most people believed him,
but then may rolled around and things started to unravel on the 18th special
prosecutor. Archibald Cox was appointed shortly thereafter.
The secret white house taping system was discovered. Not.
Cox was all like, ah, so you've been recording your conversations.
This entire time. Well, if I have a listen to Richard, Nixon was like, uh,
no, you can't, but I'll tell you what's on the tape. Stop. Proving my innocence.
Tiredly innocent as the climate grooves or release the tapes.
Nixon's paranoia at reaching new Heights in his hands.
It was everything had ever fed shadowy elite teaming up with a Jewish reporter,
just screw over the poor blue collar.
Dick Nixon convinced he had enemies everywhere.
The 37th president lashed out in the most self-destructive way possible.
The Saturday night massacre on October the 20th,
1973 was a turning point in the scandal in quick succession, Nixon fads,
both as attorney general and deputy attorney general for refusing to fire
Archibald Cox before his solicitor general agreed to carry out the order.
Half an hour later, Nixon ordered the FBI to seal it off Cox's his offices.
It was supposed to kill the investigation through force,
but instead it created outrage in the house. Impeachment charges were filed.
Petly Republicans began to speak out against the president.
Chastised Nixon was forced to hire a new special prosecutor, Leon Jaworski.
By now it was clear that the presidents had something to hide.
The rest of the story plays out with painful inevitability.
There's the infamous. I'm not a crook speech in November, 1973, the March,
1974 in diamonds of seven Nixon AIDS by a grand jury.
As the subpoena for the white house tapes,
the Supreme court battle that ruled against Nixon on July the 24th,
forcing him to release them. After that, it was all over on August the fifth,
1974, the first transcripts of the tapes appeared in the media.
They included Nixon directing the CIA to interfere with the FBI's investigation.
The president of this recording, the smoking gun.
The strangest thing about Watergate in hindsight is that Nixon really didn't
have anything to do with the break-in creep.
And the plumbers really had gone rogue and Nixon could have probably weathered
that smaller scandal instead he chose to cover it up.
And that was a much bigger deal. Following the release of the transcripts.
Congress moved to impeach Nixon.
It's almost certain the votes with that remove him from office,
but Nixon never gave them the chance on August the eighth of 1974,
Richard Nixon announced his resignation,
the only president in history to do so at noon the next day he and his family
left by helicopter.
As they departed Nixon turned grinned and flashed D V sign for victory.
And so ended Dick Nixon's presidency less than a month later on September the
eighth, the new president, Gerald Ford issued a blanket. Pardon? For any crimes,
Richard Nixon may have committed while in office.
It was a hugely unpopular move. And one that likely handed the Democrats,
the white house in 1976, but there was nothing anyone could do.
Dick Nixon was now Mandy would always be a free man.
The only question now was what to do with all this unexpected,
A huge amount to say about Nixon's life. After the white house, he ends passing,
moved back to California, settled in San Clemente. At first,
the disgrace president kept his head low,
but legal fights that so sapped his bank accounts that he returned to public
life just to get his money back.
And so we got the unedifying spectacle of the frost Nixon,
which earns Nixon $600,000 into the publication of his memoirs,
which netted him 2 million yet,
even though Nixon remained a hugely divisive figure with the public.
Those on Capitol Hill could never quite let go of him across the next 15 years.
Presidents, Jimmy Carter,
Ronald Reagan and George H w Bush all came to consult with tricky.
Dick searching out his experience in foreign policy by 1990,
the image of Nixon as an elder statesmen had so ended the political class,
that three ex presidents came to the opening of his library in a weird way.
This was everything Nixon had ever dreamed of here.
He was a man who had committed high crimes and misdemeanors yet had not only
never faced justice, but was now being publicly on it.
Does that sound like a blue collar kid from the sticks or like a member of the
privileged elite? Richard Nixon finally died on April the 22nd,
1994 at his funeral president bill Clinton,
and gave a stirring eulogy that ended with the words may the day of judging
president Nixon on anything less than his entire life and Korea come to a close.
The political rehabilitation of Richard Nixon was now so total that Watergate
was seemingly forgotten. But the story doesn't end that today,
the Watergate scandal is older than me for starters,
but major stuff like star Wars,
the Iranian revolution and the entire countries of Angola.
So Lakia or Mozambique in shorts, it's history,
something that happened in the dim and distant past yet.
Somehow we still remember it in a world where even major political scandals like
Iran contrary, or the Pentagon papers have slipped from the public's mind.
That's really saying something for whatever reason.
Watergate has become only more notorious.
It's now the gold standard of scandal.
No matter how hard the political class may have tried,
it would always stain Nixon's name.
And yet there is no denying that there was more to the 37th president than a
single scandal. Richard Nixon was a complex, flawed and brilliant man.
He was insecure and bullying,
but also a man who understood the pain of being an outsider,
an ordinary man who really thought he could change his country for the better
too often in history and politics. We'd like to paint simple narratives.
This man is a monster. This man is a Saint blah, blah, blah.
But real life is necessarily simple. And as men like Nixon,
I never simply caricatures cartoon villains that to be laughed at they're human
beings, really heart really care, and sometimes even managed to do some good.
Richard Nixon may be long gone now,
but the lessons we learned from his presidency should stay with us forever.
It's easy to hate such a man, but it takes real guts to try to understand him.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video. If you did,
please do hit like do subscribe also,
thanks to ground news for sponsoring this video,
bringing together news from all sides of the political spectrum from around the
globe. So you can get all the perspectives and form your own opinion.
The app is free and you can check it out through the links below.
Thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].